l'union européenne telle qu'elle est
organisée est telle qu'elle est orientée
politiquement et bien nous amène dans le
mur et on le voit avec cette pièce comme
axe inalp s'agit de cela on nous a
toujours dit que l'union européenne
s'était l'échelon d'efficacité en cas de
crise la crise financière en 2008
l'union européenne était inopérante la
crise migratoire en 2015
l'union européenne était absente
incapable de protéger ses frontières
extérieures et aujourd'hui avec la crise
sanitaire
l'union européenne n'était pas à la
hauteur de l'anticipation à la hauteur
de la coordination les états membres se
sont organisés entre eux et la commande
groupée vaccinale qui a suscité c'est
vrai un espoir est bien aujourd'hui
s'avère être un échec total et vous
l'avez souligné en préambule les pays
qui ont acheté par eux mêmes de leur
propre initiative des vaccins sans
oeillères idéologiques
y compris d'ailleurs en ce moment mais à
des vaccins produits par la chine par la
russie et bien aujourd'hui s'en sortait
mieux et les britanniques qui ont quitté
l'union européenne
à la fin de l'année 2020 et bien
aujourd'hui soit un niveau de
vaccination qui est quatre fois
supérieur à la france à l'allemagne à
l'italie ou à l'espagne
[Musique]